crazy stat alert here we go only 23 of
student loan debt holders understood the
cost of attending college before they
took out yeah loans yeah
one out of one out of four understood
what they were getting themselves into
ridiculous and 35 percent of those
student loan debt holders did not fully
understand their potential for earnings
following graduation roi on your
investment david what's roi uh return on
investment i think there's
obviously yeah i think there's this
thing where
you're kind of fed this like oh student
loans i mean everyone has student loans
it's not really going to affect just
take it and you pay pay the minimum and
then in 10 years whatever you say you
can't pay it and whatever yeah but it's
still this like heavy collected i i have
student loans yeah boy do i have student
loans how much do you have
50k
anyway so anyway let's let's harp on
dave we'll figure that out we'll put a
plan for that so anyway no matter how
fun college or the college experience is
it's not worth being in debt for 20
years that's the average amount of the
time that it takes to pay off student
loan debt it's like a it's like a but
loose noose around you but i don't
regret it you know like i don't know if
it's kind of like this uh i'm not saying
you should survive i read it
yeah i don't know it's like i would have
still gone to college
i had a great time in college i learned
a lot and i'm that's true part of i'm
here at valuetainment because of what i
learned in college and the connections
i'm in college matter of fact the person
that brought me here was someone i met
in college awesome
awesome so it's like
okay but that's that's a reason to go to
college because you knew what you wanted
to do
you found a career path in your field
true you made a connection while in
college yeah and you utilized that to
get you an interview here right so that
was like kind of the point of going to
college the problem is when people go to
college
they don't utilize their major they go
into a different field they make no
connections they don't utilize the
connections they go to college for two
years they drop out
that's a waste of money in my opinion
right we talked about college experience
right so you know people want to go
apart like the what's the girl's name
whose mom was uh oh well becky from full
house she's like i just want to go to
college to party
i just want to i just it's i'm there for
the party a lot of people do that yeah i
get it i get a degree in communication
but you don't need to go to college to
to go party
you go party without college or forget
about college taking out a hundred
thousand dollars of student loan debt
that's the greatest that's what it is
it's like how much of a party exactly
how much was that damn party yeah it's a
pretty expensive bottle of vodka 50
grand yeah yeah
all right so because the whole point of
going to college the whole point of a
career is to eventually reach financial
independence yeah but if you can't get
to being financially independent or what
i call being chilling what's the point
right so anyway
i know we spent a lot of time on this
but this is a major story millennials
and gen z running the country right now
millennials largest generation in the
workforce
and uh gen z they're the cool kids
they're the cool kids and i think the
bottom line here is that the american
dream has changed the american dream has
changed it used to be
you work you'd be one of the lucky few
to go to college or you'd work for the
same company for 40 years you'd retire
they give you a gold watch pension see
you later you lived to maybe 67 you were
collecting uh social security by 65
maybe you had a two three year of social
security you get by boom you die by a
rocking chair down by the sea that
doesn't happen anymore that's not the
american dream anymore white picket
fence you know two and a half kids dog
for like the things have changed what
the american dream now
is in my opinion is being able to own
your time being able to do what you want
with your time when you want to be doing
it look at me right now this is what i
actually want to be doing yeah exactly
this is my dream mother sucker
this is it look at everyone look at me
just look at me king and the guest
here i go but the american dream is
financial freedom being able to own your
times you know i rant about saving that
money save that money what's up why do i
save that money right it's so i can do
what i want with my time okay
so there's a bigger picture there's a
money mentality or a money or a savers
mentality a bigger picture or a mindset
that you need to understand look
am i wearing a watch no watch i could
ride a rolex i could spend 10 grand on a
rolex and not even think about it but
instead of buying that 10 grand rolex
i bought bitcoin okay
i can afford a house i really could i
could put a hundred grand down on a
house no problem i like the flexibility
i like being able to move around i
invest in the stock market because i can
take that anywhere i go right
i can afford a mercedes-benz how much is
uh
how much is it how much does a mercedes
benz you think about 50 grand that's
fine i could do that
but i'd rather just uber around and not
have my car sit there for 95 of the day
these are the lifestyle changes the
choices that i've made
to make me a millionaire because the
bottom line is this i'd rather do things
than buy things yeah
okay little shout out to young john he
got the spongebob reference with a look
at him okay
so but i agree yeah
and at the end of the day
i'd rather be wealthy than look rich you
know who looks rich the guy with the you
see the pricks he's he's got you've seen
this picture on instagram it's the guy
with
pushing the mercedes with his rolex
holding a starbucks cup like look at me
i'm rich i'm in a time of my life coffee
yeah that guy's broke that guy is more
often than not
look at his ballot
the point is this i'd rather be wealthy
than look rich okay i like the
flexibility rather than having all the
payments right and that's the bottom
line
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken